How many holes does a woman have down there?
Two.
Three. Which one is it?
Three. Three.
Okay, okay.
How many holes does a woman have down there?
Um, I think a lot.
Read the fit. How many holes does a woman have down there?
I don't know. Oh,
I thought you were gonna get it.
Where are you?
I don't know. Don't know.
How many holes does a woman have down there?
I hear there's three.
Should men have a say in women's reproductive rights?
Um, well, um,
it all depends. You don't even know how many holes they have, bro.
Ha ha ha ha. Let's be fucking for real.
Should you have a say so in a woman reproductive.
We don't even know how many holes they have.
Should men have a say so in women's reproductive rights?
Oh, that's a political question.
Not my answer. Can't answer a political.
Do you think that should be political?
Like, as men,
what if doctors told us we couldn't get fucking surgeries?
Should that be political or should be common sense?
Tough answer. Tough answer.
Tough answer. Should men have a say in women's reproductive rights?
Fuck, no.
Fuck, yeah.
Like this guy. Should men have a say so in women's reproductive rights?
That's it. Stupid question.
There's no such thing as stupid questions.
But that's okay. That's stupid.
What's the stupid answer is what's understood
doesn't need to be explained.
Absolutely not. Yes